-It's great to see you,
as always.
I've missed you, pal.
-You too.
-It's always good to see you,
man.
Doesn't that feel good, huh?
That audience?
-No.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It doesn't.
It doesn't feel good.
-I'm kidding.
It feels great.
It's nice to see all you guys.
We've all been cooped up
in our house.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know they just announced
this thing last week,
that you're going to play
Jerry Garcia in a movie
with Martin Scorsese directing.
-Yes. Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love it.
I think it's fantastic.
How did it come about?
And --
-This is a cool story
that I'll tell,
if anyone's watching,
that needs to improve
their voice of self-doubt
in their heads.
Okay?
-We're all listening.
-So, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I'm sure.
I do -- I suffer from it.
So, COVID started.
I started my company,
Strong Baby Productions.
Shout-out,
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we had just started
the company.
And I'm on Instagram.
COVID just started.
We're all stuck in our houses.
And I see this picture
of Jerry Garcia when he's young,
and I'm like,
"Wow.
Why has nobody done this?
Why hasn't anyone made a movie?
I could play Jerry Garcia."
And then, I spent
the next hour and a half, like,
talking myself out of it,
being like,
"Don't show anyone this.
Don't say this.
You're gonna sound insane.
You're not good enough.
You're not this.
You're not that."
And, you know, "He's an icon,
and that's just a picture."
And I finally did the work
in my head to go,
"No, share it with
the people you work with."
So I sent it to my company
and to my manager, Rick, and --
and they were like,
"This is a great idea."
And then,
Rick manages Martin Scorsese.
And we worked together
on "Wolf of Wall Street,"
and he said, "You know who would
love this is Martin Scorsese."
And my partner Matt and I
were like, "Yeah, for sure.
That sounds great."
[ Laughter ]
Like, "Yeah, I'm sure you --
yeah.
I bet he'll like it a lot."
And we're like,
"What is happening?"
And then, Marty said, yes,
he wanted to direct a movie
about the Grateful Dead
with me playing Jerry Garcia.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So it goes from zero --
-It goes to, I shouldn't even
send this because I am not
valuable enough
to even express an idea
to having your hero
direct a movie
about your nother hero,
you know?
-Yeah.
-And so it's a beautiful story.
-Actually, it's happening.
Oh, my goodness.
-Yeah, so that's really cool,
yeah.
-Buddy, I can't wait for this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm so excited.
So they're writing it now?
-Yeah, Larry and Scott,
my favorite writers,
who were, like,
"People vs. Larry Flynt"
and "Ed Wood" and stuff,
they're writing it now.
And -- And it's exciting.
Let's hope it works out.
-I'm so psyched for you, man.
-Thank you.
-You also directed this movie
I want to --
It's gonna be on Netflix.
-Yeah.
-You were telling me backstage.
Explain this.
-I directed my second movie.
It's a documentary, and it's
about therapy, in general.
And sort of getting therapy
out to the masses of people
whose families and cultures
stigmatize it
and who can't afford it.
And it's through the prism of me
and my therapist --
my actual therapist.
So it's an insane idea.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's an insane movie.
I'm pretty sure we deal
with a lot of how insane,
ethically, it is for a patient
to be making a movie
about their therapist with them.
[ Laughter ]
But, ultimately, the idea
is to explore how therapy
has helped me in my life
and give that
to as many people as possible
would be awesome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love that.
-Yeah.
-I also want to talk about
"Don't Look Up."
This is your new movie.
-What's that now, sweetheart?
[ Laughter ]
"Don't Look --"
-"Don't Look Up" is the film
I'm in -- got it.
Okay. Yes. Great.
[ Laughter ]
Wow, I must be rusty, dude.
'Cause --
-Whoa!
You get rusty?
-Yeah.
-What do you mean?
You felt rusty,
or you feel it now?
-I felt --
Let's slow it down.
Let's slow the pace down.
-I was going --
I was going a bit too much.
-Not you.
Is our connection weird?
[ Laughter ]
-No. That's --
-Like, has stuff changed
between us?
-No. Is it me? You're not
feeling the vibe here?
-I think I'm being
broken up with by the world.
-What are you talking about?
[ Audience shouting ]
-Okay.
I love you guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-Sorry.
-I -- You know...
I thought I was getting dumped
for a second.
-Are you kidding me?
-Yeah.
-Never in your life.
-Thank God. Okay.
-We will never,
ever let you down.
We'd never dump you.
-Thank you.
-This should be your home.
Yeah, I'm gonna move in here.
-You're welcome.
You're welcome to move here.
-Thanks, guys.
I want to talk to you about
you new film.
-"Don't Look Up" --
awesome movie
directed by Adam McKay.
Legend.
Love McKay, dude.
-Adam McKay is a genius.
He's brilliant.
I want to talk about it
in the next segment.
But I want -- you brought
something with you
that you've been using on the --
-On the press tour.
Now I do kind of
know what this is.
-Okay. So this is a really bad,
like, 8-year-old style,
old-school fart machine.
[ Laughter ]
It literally says,
"Fart Machine #2" on it, okay?
[ Laughter ]
-That's really funny.
-And it's huge and absurd
and crazy.
This is what it sounds like.
-All right.
-This is how digital
and dumb it sounds, okay?
[ Fart sounds ]
[ Laughter ]
Okay?
Like, funny for, like,
a 6-year-old maybe, right?
-Sure.
-So did I a movie
with Julia Louis-Dreyfus,
and she's the coolest.
And I was saying, "I'm going
to do press for this movie,
'Don't Look Up,'" with all these
huge movie stars in it,
like Leonardo DiCaprio
and Meryl Streep
and Jennifer Lawrence
and Tyler Perry,
et cetera, et cetera,
Rob Morgan.
And I'm like,
"Wouldn't it be funny
if I'm with all these
fancy people and I have, like,
a really stupid
3-year-old fart machine, right?"
[ Laughter ]
And so Julia, being awesome,
gets me this
as a wrap gift, okay?
And so I've been working
with the machine for a few --
for a few days now.
[ Laughter ]
And we did this big,
fancy press conference,
and I did the fart machine
when someone was talking about
climate change, and I -- I...
[ Audience "Ohs" ]
...I hit the fart machine
like that, right?
My castmates did --
did not find it funny.
[ Laughter ]
Meryl Streep, being the
O.G. legend that she is,
did find it funny,
which is why I ride for her
any time, day or night.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right.
Meryl Streep.
-Okay?
-Meryl Streep is what's up.
-So then, Adam McKay,
the director of this giant,
fancy film, that is amazing,
by the way, he says,
"Jonah --"
And he's a funny guy.
You've known McKay forever.
And he goes,
"Jonah, you're gonna
get a kick out of this.
Netflix, who made the movie,
has, like, formally asked me
multiple times to ask you
formally to stop using
the fart machine
during press for the film."
Like, they don't find it funny,
and they don't find it
interesting."
And I found that hilarious,
right?
So, in that, they have now
formally asked me --
And people I work with
that I pay,
they can't say,
"Stop using that,"
but they're like
"Hey, you know, we --
we find it funny, you know?
We -- We get the joke, you know?
But it's just Netflix.
You know, whatever."
-"The suits upstairs."
And so I just want to say
officially, I love you, Netflix.
I love working with you.
I am a huge fan.
I watch your streamer,
but no corporate entity
will ever silence
my digital farts, mother [bleep]
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
♪♪
-More with Jonah Hill
when we come back!
Stick around, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Fart sounds ]